[Music]
what
a difference a day may
[Music]
24 little hours
[Music]
brought the sun and the flowers
where there used to be rain
my yesterday was
come on down here and join the party
come on
[Music]
my lonely nights
[Music]
lord what a difference a day makes
there's a rainbow before me
skies above can't be
stormy
and which one of seattle's daughters is
here i'm aretha louise
well nice to meet you aretha i'm ted
white
it's heaven when you
find romance on your
menu
what a difference the
and the difference is you
my daughter aretha oh ciel don't make
reesing if she doesn't want to re
listens to the radio
she can hear any song and sing it back
nope nope
and tonight we got a bona fide radio
star in
our house yeah
so so how would y'all like to hear a
little sing-alongs little uh
call and response hey
was it like a little parlor trick
something like that no
louise good
did you say i've got a lot to learn
did you say i've got a lot to learn
[Applause]
this is the perfect spot to learn
teach me tonight
[Applause]
you got something there that's it reid's
gonna be the next great one
yes she is yes
[Music]
you